[Musica]
gaia è bellissima
gaia e piena di vita gaia è una madre
gaia ha sempre goduto di un ottima
salute
però ultimamente sulla sua pelle sono
apparsi dei disturbi mai visti prima
forse una mutazione di qualche organismo
tra i molti presenti a differenza però
di tutti gli altri organismi
gli ultimi arrivati dapprima innocui ci
sono rivelati poi essere dei veri e
propri parassiti interessati solo al
proprio benessere
vorrei che tutti si comportano la stessa
maniera
però nessuno di essi può dirsi esente da
colpe
questi minuscoli esserini hanno fatto
male i propri conti con il loro
comportamento opportunistico hanno fatto
ammalare gaia che ora rischia di
aggravarsi
e se gaia muore anche loro moriranno
volete sapere come finisce questa storia
novero posso raccontare perché
semplicemente non è ancora successo
ciascuno però può immaginare la
conclusione che preferisce personalmente
questa storia mi ha letteralmente
folgorato da ragazzo e ha fatto nascere
in me una gran voglia di fare qualcosa
per gaia mi sembrava impossibile che non
ci si potesse fare nulla solo
rassegnarsi a un progressivo decadimento
poi però qualche giorno dopo la laurea
in ingegneria meccanica
mi chiamavano proprio qui vicino alla
nordica
e fini a fare ricerca e sviluppo sugli
sci mentre la storia di gaia pian piano
si confondeva tra i mille pensieri della
quotidianità
dopo anni e mezzo ne arriva questa che
mi cambiò la vita con veniva dal
consorzio rfx di padova e diceva più o
meno così la fusione nucleare potrebbe
essere l'energia del futuro ci servono
ingegneri per costruire macchine
avveniristiche che potrebbero un giorno
produrre energia in maniera pulita e
inesauribile vuoi venire a darci una
mano pubblica mi resi conto che la
storia di gaia in realtà non era morta
dentro di me ma era solo schiacciata dal
peso della quotidianità potete
immaginare quale fu la mia scelta che
però mi costrinse a lasciare a
licenziarli da un lavoro a tempo
indeterminato a due chilometri da casa
per andare a fare un dottorato di
ricerca dalle prospettive diciamo così
un po fumose ma non sapete quanto mi
sbagliavo
pensate per avere l'ambito posto fisso
ci sono voluti solo di cianni
comunque adesso che sono ricercatore col
tempo fisso e col posto fisso anche da
qualche mese
vorrei fare con voi quello che faccio
tutti i giorni nel mio laboratorio
padovano cioè un bell'esperimento e
chiederei perciò di alzare la mano a
quelli tra di voi che ricordano durante
la loro infanzia degli inverni più
freddi rispetto come sonora
beh vedo che quasi tutti avete alzato la
mano e questo vuol dire un paio di cose
che gaia un po di febbre
c'è da sé che questa febbre e anche in
aumento ma perché gaia alla febbre
un suggerimento ci viene dall andamento
della co2 nell'atmosfera di gaia negli
ultimi 10.000 anni è costante fino a che
intorno al 1800 comincia a crescere come
una rampa improvvisa e sorprendente che
la porta ad essere il 50 per cento in
più di come era prima dell'ottocento è
come se il grasso sottocutaneo di gaia
fosse aumentato di colpo del 50 per
cento
sfido che la venuta la febbre è infatti
anche la temperatura che per tanto tempo
è rimasta costante la temperatura di
gaia intorno al 1800 comincia a crescere
a un'impennata altrettanto sorprendente
altrettanto improvvisa che l'ha portata
ad essere un grado in più
all'incirca rispetto a come era prima
dell'ottocento
ma cosa volete che sia un grado ma voi
come state quando avete un grado di
febbre esatte di avercela sempre e che
anzi sia destinata solo ad aumentare
ma cosa volete che sia se inverni sono
un po più
tiepidi adesso rispetto come erano anni
fa risparmiamo surriscaldamento no
magari si scioglie qualche ghiacciaio da
qualche parte chissenefrega
ma che succede se cominciano ad arrivare
tempeste in grado di spezzare milioni di
alberi secolari e quello che è successo
e non è successo chissà dove e successo
a marcesina e successo sovramonte è
successo malga ciapela praticamente
successo a casa nostra
stavolta e queste cose succedono solo da
quando gaia ha la febbre
sono forse i suoi colpi di tosse
forse sono il suo modo per dircelo e non
è tanto preoccupante quello che succede
oggi a gaia ma quello che potrà
succedere tra 50 a 100 tra 200 anni
chiaramente nessuno ha la sfera di
cristallo e nessuno può prevedere il
futuro però tutti possiamo guardare al
passato alla nostra storia
cosa è successo 200 anni fa che ha
creato questo macello
lo sanno tutti è molto semplice abbiamo
cominciato a bruciare i combustibili
fossili ed allora abbiamo fatto sempre
di più e sempre di più è aumentata la
quantità di co2 che abbiamo riversato
nell'atmosfera di gaia che adesso tanto
per dare un'idea si misura in decine di
miliardi di tonnellate all'anno e
purtroppo non possiamo fare altrimenti
perché siamo una specie energivora con
il nostro stile di vita
noi siamo ingordi di energia siamo gli
unici che per spostarsi in realtà
muovono 20 volte il proprio peso che
facciamo da dove cominciare
potremo prenderci tutti la macchina
elettrica no
ottima idea però così dovremo produrre
molta più energia elettrica
e che problema c'è la facciamo quei
pannelli fotovoltaici
ecco i generatori eolici che possiamo
mettere ovunque
magari fosse così facile
queste fonti energetiche sono
estremamente intermittenti quindi
possono soddisfare solo a una minima
parte del nostro enorme appetito di
energia
ma c'è anche l'idroelettrico però è
quasi tutto sfruttato c'è anche il
nucleare da fissione però produce scorie
ci sono anche i biocombustibili però
tolgono spazio alle coltivazioni per il
cibo quindi è quindi il nostro mondo
funziona ancora combustibili fossili 85
per cento dell'energia 85 per cento si
produce ancora bruciando combustibili
fossili che beninteso sono una
benedizione per noi esserini sulla pelle
di gaia ma sono anche una minaccia
micidiale per la sua salute
come si esce da questa trappola
non è facile penso che dovremmo
utilizzare un po di più
un altro tipo di energia un'inezia che
ci caratterizza come esseri umani e la
nostra energia mentale è quella che ci
tira fuori dalle crisi che hanno una
svolta grazie alla nostra creatività
alla nostra intelligenza alla nostra
capacità di cooperare ma come la usiamo
in questo caso per questa crisi è la
risposta è che non lo sa nessuno però
potremmo guardare fuori dalla finestra e
farsi ispirare da una bella giornata di
sole non come quelle che abbiamo vissuto
nelle ultime settimane quelle che
arriveranno tra poco pensate tutta
l'energia del sole è prodotta e prodotta
da una singola reazione quella di
fusione nucleare
ho detto fusione non fissione la fusione
funziona con l'idrogeno la fissione con
l'uranio e sono l'una l'opposto
dell'altra
la fusione nucleare è l'energia
primordiale dell'universo da cui tutta
l'energia deriva direttamente o
indirettamente a un sogno meraviglioso
per l'umanità quello di portarla sulla
terra per soddisfare ai nostri enormi e
crescenti bisogni di energia però non è
facile sul sole ci sono pressioni
elevatissime che schiacciano la materia
e favoriscono molto questa reazione
sulla terra non possiamo fare quelle
pressioni
però possiamo compensare con la
temperatura pensate con le nostre
macchine riusciamo a produrre
temperature dieci volte più alte di
quelle che sono le sole
nei soli 16 milioni di gradi bene con le
nostre macchine facciamo 160 e quello
che facciamo e riusciamo così a
innescare la reazione di fusione anche
sulla terra
e come mai non sono le centrali allora
perché l'energia che spendiamo per
queste macchine al momento è ancora
maggiore rispetto a quella che riusciamo
a ricavare da s
ma stiamo costruendo delle macchine che
in dieci anni puntano a ottenere 10
volte di più
l'energia che serve per farle funzionare
e con queste macchine ci faremo delle
centrali elettriche che produrranno
energia elettrica ma non potevano co2
non produrranno scorie e suoneranno con
un materiale che non è concentrato in
pochi paesi fortunati ma è abbondante
ovunque ci sia un mare l'idrogeno
certo non sono macchine facile tanto per
fare un esempio
in queste macchine a pochi centimetri di
distanza ci sono la temperatura più alta
è la più bassa che l'uomo sia mai stato
in grado di generare non è quindi
un'impresa facile la nostra e non è
detto che la reazione di fusione sarà la
cura per gaia penso sia doveroso almeno
provarci con tutta la nostra forza con
tutta la nostra energia mentale perché
la posta in gioco in questo caso è la
più alta che possiamo immaginare e con
lo stesso spirito
dovremo approvare anche qualsiasi altra
strada qualsiasi cosa utile forse vi
starete chiedendo
e io che faccio tutt'altro nella vita
cosa posso fare per gaia mai ci sono
tantissimi gesti che ciascuno può fare e
che aiutano gaia se poi li fate con la
determinazione di gaeta tim burke tanto
meglio
io sono qui per chiedervi una cosa
diversa è a favore non lasciate soli
ricercatori con questo fardello per
favore informatevi sulla salute di gaia
e immaginate se potete anche voi quale
potrebbe essere la cura per la sua
febbre
forse non troverete la soluzione però
farete qualcosa di altrettanto
importante
forse nella borsa bianca che avete
ricevuto dalle tende dall'organizzazione
del teteks avete trovato questa bustina
sono dei semi la vostra consapevolezza
sarà il terreno ideale nel quale il seme
proprio quel seme potrà germogliare e
crescere insieme della prossima
innovazione quella che potrebbe un bel
giorno curare la fredda di gaia grazie
[Applauso]